who's the best nfl quarterback you ever
played against well you saw him with
your own eyes and you were like god damn
i feel like everyone feels that way
about my homes now like some of these
throws even when he was getting the [ __ ]
kicked out of him
you know planking across the field i
mean that yeah
that's just that yeah yeah that that's
next level but like when you were
playing who did you see in person that
just were
you you you just made it and it was part
of it part of it were the throws
but just how you know you walk up to the
huddle and whatever the defense is doing
right
he'll just call it out he's doing that
he's doing that he's doing that
okay we're gonna do this we're gonna do
this and then just go and there's
when he's when he was on and then you
look over and you got [ __ ] j
fielder and you're like [ __ ] we're
[ __ ]
we're [ __ ] boys it's over
we'll be running the [ __ ] wildcat
there is no quarterback on the [ __ ]
field
i mean honestly that's that's the
feeling when peyton manning is on that's
the feeling and there's no there's
nothing
like what are we going to do nothing you
can do we got to injure him yeah
he gets and he gets rid of the ball he
got rid of the ball so fast it was
nothing you could do
man what would happen if they would have
got eddridge and james and you were
[ __ ]
if you and peyton manning were to play
together no i know i i mean
jesus christ it would have been fun it
would have been fun it would have been
insane